my dream is not to be a comedian my
dream is to become a rapper that's my
goal
and okay people always laugh at the
dream but
that's not very fair that's not very
nice if you're
in this this kind of area here what you
want to recommend
drinking wine and enjoying cupcakes well
that's that's an animal and a food
unfortunately i'm sorry because you
didn't you
going first is always hard these people
were like waiting and pausing and then
you came in
i just went in there i just went for it
you did
you did sadly it's it's verboten um so
we need another suggestion
a day in the life of you in america well
that feels again very inspired by
a suggestion they've already prompted so
you could suggest anything you could say
anything at all like
what what is it about me in america that
you're interested in
you eating your first new york bagel
okey dokey lovely that's a great
suggestion yeah okay i know it's food
but it's also centered around me
and also the set is running close to the
end and i'm worried this is going to
take far too long to get five
suggestions if this is what happened
so great thank you very much for the
koala eating wine and cake
but sadly it's going to be me eating my
first new york bagel um
in in certain jewish areas of london
they
they argue that it's pronounced uh
beigel
is that a weird accent thing that we do
that's not a thing for here is it
i don't know what you're saying cool
good good thank you good um
people in this line here yeah oh you put
a hand up there yes
but you did this you went
oh you're excited well that's good i
like your enthusiasm what would you guys
like a rapper
prince philip in the afterlife whatever
that is and what did you say at the back
he just said secret dark ritual okay
me eating a new york bagel prince philip
in the afterlife secret dark ritual
middle of the room what'd you want to
wrap though
dental damn very yes very sensible well
done and people over here what do you
want to rap about
i'll explain what a dental dam is in the
wrap don't worry
[Applause]
nuns on bicycles i wrapped about nuns on
bicycles literally a week ago in the
room above here so i can't tell that
suggestion
i know the joke that you're referencing
two nuns on a bicycle one of them says i
haven't come this way before the other
one says must be the cobbles
wait did you quote the joke and not know
it what would you like to rap about
do you floss every day is that that
that's what you wanted me to rap about
okay
cool this then lovely people it's gonna
be a freestyle rap that's a wrap made up
on the spot based on talent suggestions
not written not prepared not rehearsed
it will be about secret dart ritual
prince philip in the afterlife um
do i floss every day dental dams and
the me of new york bagel um let's drop
that beat good sir
do not worry it will not be anywhere
near as atrociously embarrassingly bad
you're expecting a privately educated
middle-class white british boy to be
it's gonna be good it's gonna be good
okay here we go
unleash me on the beat then you know i
go to town always got the dental damn
when i'm going down
don't want to get any type of std so i
always eat [ __ ] hygienically
i'll be rocking up a little bit of latex
always make sure take a magnifying glass
and inspect it for any microscopic holes
you don't want
any little thing to go through no
chlamydia
on my tongue or within my cheek i'll be
down there getting distracted when she
speaks saying chris
why did you put a condom on my puss i
say it's a dental dam
i don't want to dot my eyes and cross my
teeth properly
i mean nyc and across the street i say
let me get the accent clear i say hey
i'm walking here and i stroll to a deli
i grab myself a bagel i got my own money
so you know the boy abel i purchased one
i've got consumer greed i get a plane
everything
and a poppy seed i know what i like so i
take the first bite it's clear the smear
that's the philadelphia light
i spread it on myself a plastic knife
but that's okay then i take it in
and i'm like oh it gets stuck down
between my molars i've got to get a
little bit of floss so i can go
there i take it out cause the seeds get
stuck it's horrible
people say british teeth yuck they say
it's disgusting you can't pay attention
to your little monthly treats to the
dentist get a little bit of floss
oral b and then put it in your teeth
intraorally
if you looked inside you'd see actually
i don't floss regularly i've got gum
disease but that's
my own fault oh yes i like this very fun
talk about the gingivitis but flossing
to me
it seems so uncool like some weird dark
satanic ritual
like people in the gowns all gathering
around saying
um on their knees they're down with a
virgin they're upon an altar maybe take
a scalpel really can't fault you for
having clean porcelain skin so fresh for
the incision
i like to be satanic none of your
derision will stop me from doing this i
drink from a goat skull
i put it down everybody's quite vocal
they say chris
a virgin wouldn't you rather sacrifice a
horrible koala so i would mate like i'm
from australia
i get it off the tree and i say to you
while you're out here hanging in the
night time
the koala's like i've drunk too much
wine oh it's a mistake to stab myself
with cake
why would i do this it's a piss type i
say come on down koala yeah it looks
like a doddle and it rides away
on a bike with some cuddles like a nun
such fun when you're saying i will grab
it let me look like monochrome rocking
black and white habits
being very cool it's fun to see what was
the last one we did
i need to be in agreement with you guys
shout out again
oh yeah a broken will he go to heaven
will he go to hell he said a lot of
racist things
so well probably down we're not mistaken
he'll be knocking there with the demons
with satan
saying i'm prince philip look at my head
i've got a crown a month ago i was
already dead you'll see the picture of
me
in the land rover oh no up to heaven up
with jehovah
and the devil says sorry phil the greek
you're down with me and that's the end
of the rap
ye
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much you lovely lovely
people my name is chris turner
good night